-Making his TV debut,
performing his hit
"Favorite Song,"
please welcome Toosii!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-But nobody's gonna make you
change what you probably ♪
♪ Don't like anyway 'bout you,
darlin' ♪
♪ So you might as well ♪
♪ Mm-hmm ♪
♪ Be somebody ♪
♪ Who can make you face what
you're guardin' ♪
♪ Open up the gates
where your heart is ♪
♪ And just be yourself ♪
♪♪
-♪ Yeah, I'm on the stage
right now ♪
♪ Singin' your favorite song ♪
♪ Look in the crowd ♪
♪ And you're nowhere to be found
as they sing along ♪
♪ I say you look good
without no makeup ♪
♪ No lashes, even better when
you wake up ♪
♪ Uh-uh-uh ♪
♪ I see the look on your face ♪
♪ I see you hidin' the hate ♪
♪ I see you lookin'
for someone ♪
♪ To scoop you right off
of your feet ♪
♪ You wanna ride in a Wraith ♪
♪ You wanna go out on dates ♪
♪ You want somebody to come
bring you flowers ♪
♪ Someone to talk to for hours ♪
♪ Wash your back while y'all sit
in the shower ♪
♪ Someone to tell you,
"You're beautiful" ♪
♪ Someone to tell you
and mean it ♪
♪ Someone to tell you,
"I love you" every day ♪
♪ And don't got a reason ♪
♪ You want someone to bring you
peace, uh ♪
♪ Someone to help you sleep,
yeah ♪
♪ Someone to pick you up
when you're feelin' down ♪
♪ Feelin' lonely ♪
♪ Somebody who can make it
better ♪
♪ Somebody who can open up
those gates ♪
♪ Open up those gates
to your heart ♪
♪ Only if you'll let me ♪
♪ I'm on the stage right now ♪
♪ Singin' your favorite song ♪
♪ Look in the crowd ♪
♪ And you're nowhere to be found
as they sing along ♪
♪ I say you look good
without no makeup ♪
♪ No lashes, even better when
you wake up ♪
♪ Uh-uh-uh ♪
♪ I see the look on your face ♪
♪ I see you lookin' for peace ♪
♪ I see you tired of the hurt,
tired of the pain ♪
♪ Tired of the nights where you
can't get no sleep ♪
♪ I see you're tired thinkin'
'bout if he cheat ♪
♪ See you're tired thinkin'
'bout if you leavin' ♪
♪ See you're tired of bein'
so tired ♪
♪ And you damn sure ain't
gettin' even ♪
♪ Somebody who can make it
better ♪
♪ Somebody who can open up
those gates ♪
♪ Open up those gates
to your heart ♪
♪ Only if you'll let me ♪
♪ I'm on the stage right now ♪
♪ Singin' your favorite song ♪
♪ Look in the crowd ♪
♪ And you're nowhere to be found
as they sing along ♪
♪ I say you look good
without no makeup ♪
♪ No lashes, even better when
you wake up ♪
♪ Uh-uh-uh ♪
♪ Yeah, I see you lookin'
for peace ♪
♪ Tired of the nights where you
can't get no sleep ♪
♪ I see you're tired thinkin'
'bout if you leavin' ♪
♪ And you damn sure ain't
gettin' even ♪
-♪ Nobody's gonna make you
change what you probably ♪
-♪ Need somebody ♪
-♪ Don't like anyway 'bout you,
darlin' ♪
-♪ Need somebody ♪
-♪ So you might as well ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]